[Music]
so let's talk a little bit about sight
reading it's an extensive topic but i
just want to focus in on a few
strategies that help me out when i'm
sight reading for myself or with others
the first thing is to gather as much
information from the score before you
start playing this includes the time
signature
the key signature
tempo and also just the general gist of
the notes
in terms of the flow certain
characteristics that that pop out to you
visually the second thing is to really
prioritize rhythm and pulse
these will serve as your anchors when
you're sight reading and when you're
faced with things that you're unfamiliar
with or you're tempted to hesitate this
will keep you grounded the third thing
is to read in chunks both vertically and
horizontally
what i mean by this is to recognize sets
of notes within a chord or chords and
sets of notes within a phrase so here
instead of reading a e
a e
e c sharp looking at those as fifth
fifth sixth is much more efficient also
with phrasing this way it's possible to
look at a set of notes as one entity
[Music]
so let's take for example a sentence in
the english language
yesterday my dog ate a giant cupcake so
the strategy here is to recognize that
whole thing as a sentence and take it in
as one thing so the fourth thing is to
notice patterns and sequences this will
go a long way because to some degree you
know what to expect and almost predict
in terms of what's coming next
and also it helps you reset per module
so say that it's a pattern like here
if you screw up somewhere it's easy to
just reset in the next little module
the fifth thing is to be aware of
harmonic centers and also just the
language of the composer in general this
type of information really helps
organize the score for you and also
helps you make sense of different
accidentals and different
types of groups or whatever you see on
the page
[Music]
so this can be as simple as noticing
that certain notes have sharps or flats
in them in a consistent manner so the
sixth point is to use all the five
things that i mentioned previously
to fake in a way that
is less wrong
than the worst
type of wrong i don't know if that makes
sense but with sight reading i believe
that there is a healthy amount of
faking that is acceptable so let's go
back to that sentence example if you
glanced at that sentence and just took
three words from it and those were
yesterday eight giant
that is so much farther from the actual
meaning of the sentence than if you were
to extract dog ate cupcake
again three these three words versus
these three words
same thing with music
so going back to talking about pulse and
rhythm it's far worse to play something
really softly in the wrong rhythm than
it is to play it in the right rhythm
if you come across a chord or
something in the page that you're
absolutely not sure of just leave it out
so that's it and i'm gonna go practice
this so that i'm not sight reading it
during rehearsal
[Music]